everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
work on an old project and I I already
started working on it and it ended up
being a lot easier than I thought
so I've already finished what I said I
was gonna do for this video but what I
will do is I'll go through everything
that I've done and if there's a chance
to refactor or improve it in any way
we'll do that this would be kind of cool
to revisit that that first project that
we did just kind of go through the code
I know you know some of you were
involved in that first project but you
know a lot of you watching probably
weren't so some of this will be new to
you and I don't know I always think it's
kind of fun to go back and look at old
projects and this is a project we were
working on at least six months ago maybe
but probably more so it'll be cool to
see how long how far we've come
you know hopefully I've improved since
then so it'll be fun and that's cool
this would be kind of more laid-back
my throat's just after yesterday stream
my voice sounded all you know messed up
so maybe it's better that this is laid
back I just want to start out too by
showing you something I got today
so I work at a university right so I got
a knock on the door which is weird
because nobody comes to my office but it
was a student and who I don't know and
they had some some stuff and they're
gonna give me this card so I got a
thank-you card and I'm gonna cover up
the phone number here in case but I got
this thank-you card from a student here
you kind of see it says dear Jesse at
the top but I just kind of wanted to
share this is a student
I kind of mentored last year and he
wasn't a computer science major
he was a communications art major but he
was taking a web design course and for
his project he he wanted to do like a
really cool website so I helped them out
with he had some parallax stuff going on
that was really cool
and you all know that I'm partial to
parallax and then he also wanted to grab
data using I think I think he ended up
using Ajax I don't yeah I think he was
using Ajax to grab some data from a
Google sheet so he had all his data in a
spreadsheet so I kind of helped him out
with that and he'd come into my office
and we'd sit down and talk about it and
check out the code and so it was cool
but I don't know I just wanted to share
it so I'm gonna read the cards just
really really small so I just kind of
want to share just as an example of I
guess if you take the time to help
someone out that it can make a big
impact on their life it it might not be
that big of a deal it might not seem
like that big of a deal but it is you
know a big enough deal for this student
to leave me a gift and a card you know
after everything so it says hey I just
wanted to write you a quick thank you
for all your help this last semester I
honestly couldn't have done it without
you
so thanks I can see your live stream has
been going good I hope you're the next
YouTube star thanks again and please
keep in touch so now that was cool I
don't know about the YouTube star thing
but I don't know I just felt it felt
really cool about that and yeah I mean
it took some some hours out of my my day
here and there but I don't know who
knows the last I heard I haven't talked
to him for a while I just sent him a
message so we'll see if he responds but
the last I heard he was developing Java
developing software in Java somewhere
out near Washington DC so really cool
anyway everybody I can see all the
everyone in the latch at not O'Rourke
has to go it's gonna go help a nephew
troubleshoot motherboard in graphics
card problems oh cool thanks for
stopping by to say hi good luck with the
the motherboard issues the graphics card
issues sometimes those can be obtained
let's see
Kyle says been watching replays of your
live videos glad to watch you live
awesome really glad that you could join
live - don't be afraid to ask questions
make comments on the live chat Sergio
says hey I just want you to know that I
like the coding with Jesse series thank
you for saying that I really appreciate
that comments comments like that make me
want to keep doing it Mounier says hey
guys check out my daily coding life on
Instagram it's PL hrim oh you and I are
cool all - check it out I'm gonna copy
and paste that right now and
that way I want to forget I'll check it
out check it out later yeah that's a
good actually I'm on Instagram as well
so I do I don't know just some coding
stuff from time to time sometimes I just
post things from for my life like me
with my kids or like food but I do post
a lot of coding stuff as well so if
you're on Instagram and you want to see
some of that stuff let me know and if
you're doing coding stuff on Instagram
I'd love to see it so you know again
just let me know I think it'd be I'm
trying to follow like as many coders as
I can on Instagram it's kind of like
Twitter has their thing but Instagram
seems to have this whole different
community of coders that kind of do it's
like on a different vibe to it so I
think it's just kind of cool to see I
don't know the differences like Twitter
seems to be like all about like business
you know like let's really talk about
the code Instagram seems to be more of a
mix of here's what I'm doing with the
code but then here's kind of how my
lifestyle like here's how I handle
work/life balance and health and so it I
don't know it's kind of cool to see that
side of uh you know my fellow coders so
anyway sorry for the long intro that
talked but let me go sorry I still have
that coffee I'm gonna try my best
I have my G fuel today so G fuel if
you're watching hook me up
I'll give you shoutouts in every video
just setting me up with like the one tub
of pink lemonade flavor
I'll give you shoutouts for for a whole
month
[Music]
all right we did have a lot of pool
requests so after we do the code when I
go to answer questions at the end the
first part of it I'm gonna check the the
pool request
I'm gonna check those out and I'm gonna
give credit where it's due to those of
you that submitted some pool requests so
I really appreciate that okay cool
Munir I did get your your friend request
on Instagram on my phone so I will be
following you as soon as I'm done thank
you all right so enough of my face let's
go to some code so this is our old
project and this is the page where I've
done the most and it looks like a lot
but most of it was copy and paste so
that's why I ended up being really easy
because I when I first made the video
instead I was gonna work on this it
didn't occur to me that we already had a
page that was doing everything that we
wanted this new page to do so I had to
do a little bit of work in WordPress to
I'll go over what I've done there and
let's see let's turn on the Pomodoro
clock okay so first things first let me
show you what I wanted on the screen I
think that's a lot easier to show at
first and then go to the code so here's
what I wanted a new page called mentor
training well when I say I want it I
mean the the people that I'm making the
site for wanted we want an intersection
which right now it's just some bacon
ipsum and then this table if you
remember this project this table should
look familiar this is the nearby events
table we've just changed the name now
what I'm not sure about I remember
talking about this in a meeting months
ago but I
I'm wasn't sure if we came to a
conclusion for sure on what these field
should be I vaguely remember basically
saying just let me know what field you
want and I'll do it and I don't know if
I ever got a list so right now they have
the same fields here like the same same
headers and this data I'm pulling the
nearby events data just to give us some
sample data because I don't have any
real data for these mentor training
sessions yet but I did invite the person
in charge of content to come at it the
WordPress site and put in some some data
so hopefully we'll get some of that soon
obviously I'm not gonna go live with
this until I get the data and contest it
if you remember in this project we have
a test server on digitalocean and then
we have two live servers that were load
balancing between we also have another
server where WordPress is running and
that's where the data we're getting all
the data from so you can see with this
table it works really well on mobile one
of the problems with tables is that
often tables don't work actually I
changed this and now it goes over so
maybe I'll I'll fix that I'm not sure if
we're even going to need that heading
anyway but normally you have a table and
you try to go it's fine on a large
screen but you try to shrink it down and
there's like all this table out here and
you scroll you have to scroll over and
that's not not a good thing you never
want to have your users have to scroll
horizontally on mobile so that's why we
went with this type of table so I didn't
come up with everything on this table
it's just a modified version of what
materialized CSS had so in this project
we're not using material UI like we did
in later projects in this project we
took materialized CSS which is not
really intended for react but we made it
work eventually I'd like to redo this
so that we switch everything over to
material UI because we have some jQuery
going on I'd rather not have jQuery in
here but for now it's it's working so
I'm okay with it
and on
so with materialized the way the table
works is by default is when you get a
large screen it looks like a normal
table with your headers your headings up
at the top and then when you go small to
small screen it changes well that didn't
exactly work for us we still had a lot
of headings so just modify it slightly
to always be in the mobile version and
we added in some things like we added in
some of these icons so you can move back
and forth otherwise like normally it was
just scroll but we've we kind of found
it wasn't 100% obvious that you could
scroll we we've also added in some
sorting so you can see we can sort by
date I believe we can sort we can sort
by location as well I think oh you know
it's not working because the location
data wasn't put in I'll show you where
where we need to enter it in it was kind
of tricky to get the right data for that
so it actually does assuming you give it
permission which I have it will get your
location and use it to show you which
one is closest and which ones are
farther away all right so let's look at
the wordpress install right now so
basically i made a page that called
mentor training intro wit hat which has
the data for that and we'll see where i
pull that in and i made a custom post
site called mentor training so you see
there's nothing there right now let me
zoom in a bit and show you so we have
normal we have
eight and we have displayed date this is
important because we want we want the
date and a format that's easily readable
by JavaScript so that's why you have the
date here but then we also want the date
displayed in a way that's easily
readable by humans so I have two
different fields just a little bit more
work but it gives us a lot of freedom
with how we want to display the date and
right now it's you know the month in a
day comma year do have a question about
will you upload the video to watch later
yes I will a little definitely so if you
can't stick around don't worry about it
I'll answer your questions and I'll
upload the video and you can just check
in later if you need to okay so we have
location here and this is just the the
location text that will show up to the
user so we're usually just doing like
city and then state sometimes I guess if
you wanted to you could put an actual
address here and then down here is where
you put in your actual location so we
have a map yeah this is a Google map yes
we have a Google map you can search for
an address and put a pin in there and
then it will send the exact coordinates
for that location and then that's how
we're comparing the coordinates that are
given when we turn on the geolocation
for the browser we compare that to the
coordinates that were given from that
Google map for each event and that's how
we figure out which ones are closer and
which ones are farther away so if you
want to know more about how we did that
go back and check out some of the early
streams the titles are pretty
descriptive on those so you will find
some about using geolocation with react
okay so now that we have all this let's
get to the code so here's the actual
components
we make some space here let me know if
this font is too small for you all so
nothing really special here we're
bringing you know if you're familiar
with react we're bringing in react we're
bringing in some components here and
we're pulling in data so we did make use
next J s to build this so we have access
to this get initial props function where
we can pull in data and then that data
is available to us on a server and the
client which is awesome and great for
server-side rendering awesome hey just
got an email from the Content Manager
for this website that we're working on
right now let's see what she said
all right so nothing she's just gonna
add some stuff later on and also wants
to have a rough timeline for all the
other updates so I was hoping she'd be
ready to put some data in we could
actually test it let's see all right so
we're in their skin initial props
function and we're getting so we're
using the WordPress REST API so no graph
QL and we have we're sending basically
this long string saying what we we need
to get so we're using a plug-in it lets
us get multiple posts and post types in
one request we have multiple post type
the trade-off when you use this plug-in
is you can't specify a lot of like what
you want so we can either get multiple
post types and they get everything or we
can do one post type and narrow it down
and only get certain fields so that was
a trade-off we but we needed to get more
than one post type so that's what we
ended up doing it like this so right now
I'm bringing in nearby events like I
said this will change and will actually
pull in the mentor training dates and
locations but right now we don't have
that data we're doing some filtering
we're gonna order it by by date and
ascending and we want some of these
fields but then on our second type with
our page so we can't we can't get like
different fields so we can say what
feels we want but it's it's not gonna
what I be able to do it for more than
one post type so for instance with pages
we're getting all the pages
I can't specify one specific page so
down here I need to when I bring in that
that intro section
I'm gonna do a filter so we're going to
this profs data so the data we get is
stored in props and then we're gonna
filter the post by the slug which is
mentor training intro that means it's
going to pool that text in that we had
in that we had here right it pulls that
text in from WordPress and it displays
it here also there's supposed to be an
image back here I don't know what would
happen but the image quit showing it
stopped showing up right before I
started this dream so I was in the
middle of troubleshooting so that's how
we pull it in and we have just a div and
we're setting the the content we're
using dangerously set inner HTML because
we want to preserve the HTML that's
coming to us from WordPress and then
down here is where we have our our table
and we're also doing a map function over
that that data that we're pulling in
which right now is the nearby event data
and we're just mapping over that and
adding our TRS and our TDS for each one
of those so that's not really the
exciting part that's kind of like basic
react stuff you you just loop over
things and add them here's where we're
doing some of the different sorting
things so we actually this is where the
jQuery comes in we have this H scroller
function that's being called and we use
some some jQuery of coming from another
file to do that but we wait and call it
on component did mount so we don't have
the document dot ready function like
we'd normally do instead we call our
jQuery from inside component did mount
and that way we know that the component
and that the the Dom elements that we
want the
to manipulate are actually loaded so
that was kind of a little workaround
that we had to do this is not ideal for
react so this is something that we had
to do to get the site launched on time
we were converting it from a site that
already basically was doing all this
stuff but it was using jQuery so I'm not
saying we should do it like this but if
you have to do something like this
that's how you make the jQuery work let
me know if you actually want to see how
we did this in jQuery you know go ahead
and I can for sure show you just let me
know in the lab chat if you're
interested so for the date sorting right
we need to get today's date obviously
and one thing we're doing is we're not
showing any dates that are before today
so we automatically don't display events
that have already happened right which
makes sense the whole point of the table
is to find events for you to go to you
can't go to it if it already happened so
that's why we're grabbing today's date
and we're also getting the location so
we're using this navigator dot geo
location get current position and what
will happen here is the user will be
prompted to allow geolocation if the
user allows it then we can get the
location if not then the location
sorting functionality will not work
which is okay that's entirely up to the
user if that's something they they would
like to do
and then we're calling compare location
so once we get the users location and
where we're saving all this into state
so our state see we have user latitude
lose user longitude all right we're
gonna store that there and here's where
we're doing some some fun stuff I
remember when we made this it was really
cool when we got it working so we have
our data we made a constant called new
data and it's just all the data that we
have in state in this state data and
we're mapping over each event and we've
actually taking each second here I was
in private location that all right so
we're checking to make sure that that
event has the location map property
right so we don't want to try to do this
if the event does not have a value for
that we're you know that would
potentially give us errors or at the
very least it would have event show up
as being really close and really far
away and it's it's not really true it's
just that there's no value there I
forget what the would actually happen if
we didn't check but that's why we need
to check so this is a just kind of a
long ternary so think I'd like a ternary
like a shorthand for an if statement so
if we have this location map property
then so after the question mark is then
we do this so then we take the user
latitude minus the latitude of that
event plus the user longitude minus the
longitude of the event
and what that gives us is a number and
the higher the number yeah let me double
check I believe it is the higher the
number the farther away the event is the
lower the number the closer the event is
so it ended up being I was a little bit
worried about how are we gonna judge
these distances I was thinking we'd have
to make another API call to some other
service to get that but no just very
simple math I mean literally addition
and subtraction got us through here
that's why I ended up being really
pleased with this as I thought this is
such a very like a simple solution to
our problem and then we have let's see
if there is no location then we do
infinity I forget why we had to do
infinity honestly I'd have to go back
and watch the stream but this wasn't my
idea somebody else put this in here to
solve some problem and then we're just
returning the event clone which was our
constant up here now we can sort alright
so if you've never used sort it's
actually it's really cool so we're
sorting each each item right so a would
be like the first item in in this array
and then B would be the second item in
this array so we remember we have an
array of objects that's the format that
our data is in so if item 1 this
distance to event no here's how we doing
sorry it's this is not if this is this
is to Evette minus the distance to event
basically what this does is compares all
of them and then sorts them so the the
ones that have the lowest value will
come
first and then it'll go up all right we
got through that it feel free to ask me
to clarify this even more and like if
you see something and you're not sure
about it you like here it might be a
little complicated like check it out on
mdn Mozilla developer Network just type
in like JavaScript sort it'll be one of
the first links and then you could
probably get some like more simple
examples and a better explanation I'm
happy to answer your questions but I
know I'm not as good as em the end so
that's why I'm just I'm throwing that
out there for you all right we're doing
a similar thing with a date right so
we're sorting by date you can see the
same thing we have a sort we're doing
the date sort
oh here we are so we have a sort here
and okay so we're actually able to do
ascending and descending with a date and
we store that in state why would we
store that value in state I feel like
I'm a teacher now sorry sorry but we
want to store it in state because every
time state changes it triggers a
rerender in our component so to go back
here if I didn't have this saved in
state I could click on date all day long
and nothing would happen right I could
uh it would be doing something in the
click but it would never trigger a
rerender so this isn't like I would put
an on click handle on there and it would
do stuff that's not how it works and
reacts
I mean potentially you could do it but
that's not really the react way and so
that's why we put that in in state and
I've done that for a couple different
projects some projects that I didn't
stream is I had to use this for like for
my Udacity nano degree some of those
projects anytime you have to do any kind
of sorting I found it always helpful to
put that
sorting in states or if you're using
Redux you can put it in there as well
but when you do that and you have a you
know some sort of toggle where you're
going to drop down we have multiple
things to soar by it's that's the way
you want to do it to trigger the
rerender all right let's see okay cool
so here we have our handle sort we're
passing in sort by so if this syntax
looks weird to you it's it's called an
arrow function so just if you want to
look up more about it type in arrow
function JavaScript you'll see a ton of
stuff it's part of the es6 syntax or
it's officially called es2015 but a lot
of people say es6 so handle short and
then this is the parameter that we're
passing in and then here's our arrow
function this looks like an arrow so
that's the that's where you get to to
our arrow function from and then
anything in here is actually our
function so we have this sort by and
it's just a switch statement so if we
want to sort by date then we have the
name date passed in here if we want to
sort by location we do that
the default is sort date so if we have
nothing in here defaults to sort date
and let's see I don't remember why we
needed two digits here something I
needed to change the two digits so
that's why you made this function but
that's basically it that's how we did
this sortable responsive table you can
check out this code and get out I
haven't pushed this yet but if you go to
the events Jas component it has all the
same stuff I just copied it from there
so you can check it out right now in the
repo this project is called CI react so
CI - react
and you can go through that you know
feel free to clone the project mess
around with it you use the code for your
own projects it's totally cool to do
that and let's see so that's that's
about it like I said I'm not ready I'm
not ready to commit this yet because I
messed up oh I messed up something so we
don't see the the background image so I
don't really want to commit it with yes
something messed up so I think I just I
changed the idea and I think that's what
messed it up but it's missing some CSS
somewhere that needed so potentially I
could just change the ID back maybe I'll
try it right now
see if it works
oh yeah
yeah that was it it's just the ID so for
now actually I will commit this because
okay so because the ID I'm not doing
anything special with this page it's I
do want it to be identical to the events
page in a sense so let me commit this
now and that way you all can see
everything so just walk you through the
process here I'm gonna do a get status
now this is on the branch called upgrade
I have not put any of this on master yet
so just be aware of that it won't be
there by default on master you have to
change the branch to upgrade I'll show
you all how to do that in a second so
I've added this and I've changed some
things in the kettle component and I've
changed some things in the Styles now I
just made a few adjustments there are
some things that I didn't like how it
looked on the page so that's that's what
I didn't hear just very small
adjustments on just like size of things
and padding and margins so let's go get
add and I'm gonna put a period there and
that's gonna add everything so now if I
do a get status again we can see in
green here these are all ready to be
committed so now we can do git and when
they're ready to be committed that's
called being staged so this is like
these are all in the stage part of the
process of get committing so now we're
gonna commit and I'm gonna do a flag - M
which means we're gonna do a commit
message and let's see we want let's see
an admin to a training page looks good
Oh what's going on I messed up something
the vent section is defined but never
used oh okay
not a big deal let's check it out so we
have some linting that runs and some
auto formatting that happens when we go
to commit and this is very useful
because it caught this obviously this
isn't an error that would have caused
their app to crash but we still would
rather not push that so we're just going
to go up to the top here and see this
event section we I took that out because
that was not needed for this particular
page but I forgot to take out the import
so if I go back in I just press the up
arrow key it brings my message right
back up my last command I get it enter
again and we'll redo that hopefully
we're good now yeah alright awesome so
everything works it told me I need to
upgrade but other than that everything
everything works and now we're just
gonna do a git push origin upgrade right
because I want to push this to the
update Ridge
and there we go everything's there let's
double check that and I'll show you how
to get to it let me make this a bit
bigger and increase the font size so I
can get to it easily because it's one of
my repositories here but if we go to fu
s fu s - mark on is FES - Markham is the
organisation and the project is CI -
react we go down here right now we're on
the master branch and you see there's
not very many updates because we've been
doing all the latest updates on the
upgrade branch so we just click that
drop down go to upgrade and see now we
have some updates that are a minute ago
those are what we just we just did right
so you can go into where we're at pages
mentor training and here you can see
everything that we just went over so I
know a lot of you are really familiar
with this and you don't you don't need
the explanation but we do have some
people who are very new to coding and
some people that don't really know
anything at all about coding that watch
so this kind of explanation I think is
helpful hopefully you know some of you
are new you don't have to say you're new
I don't if you're gonna be embarrassed
by admitting that you know you're you
don't know anything about github or
something like that I don't think you
have to be embarrassed but I totally
understand if you don't want to say it
but hopefully that helps you all I know
it adds a little bit of time to the
stream but I want to be as
beginner-friendly as I possibly can all
right so at this point we need a drink
and at this point since we're already on
github I'd like to show you awesome of
the pool requests that were made and and
thank everyone that submitted pool
requests and I'm just gonna kind of go
over what's what's changed it looks like
I have a message here about the side
menu let's check it out
all right cool so on hell is is working
on that react native app that we're
making so we're taking the resource
center which we already made and react
and we're just converting it to be able
to work in react native so if you're not
familiar throughout native that means
that we'll be able to run the Resource
Center on Android and iOS as a native
mobile application which is going to be
awesome it's going to solve some browser
issue problems that we've had I did read
an interesting article recently and I I
forget where I saw it so otherwise I'd
let you know where it's at but it was
basically making the argument that if we
really care about our users we won't
support older browsers because older
browsers are not secure so by supporting
older browsers we're enabling that
behavior and we're actually contributing
to our users being at risk like if if we
handle sensitive data and we allow
people on an old browser to actually
make transactions on our site let's say
it's an e-commerce site then we're
allowing them to put their data at risk
they probably don't even realize it so
the the I think the title of the article
was by supporting older browsers or we
really like caring for do we really care
about our users or do we care about our
business right so from a business
perspective you want everybody to be
able to buy something no matter what
browser on their own but if we're really
caring about the users wouldn't we want
to stop them from potentially leaking
their data out from an old browser so
that that's kind of changed the way I
thought about things I still like to
support
browser
to an extent but I've kind of felt the
same way in terms of supporting really
old browsers are we really doing anybody
a favor by supporting older browsers so
anyway I just it reminded me of that
because we've had issues with the
resource center not working with older
browsers and I've tried to accommodate
the older browsers but I'm not sure that
that's that's the right move
anyway if you all want to weigh in on
that please do I'm interested to see you
know what would you all think about that
so basically from from the perspective
of how we can best care for our users is
it better to support older browsers or
not support older browsers alright let's
go to a repo here and most of the
changes I'm sorry the pool request that
were merged in with for this Franciscan
react
we did have some for this react native
so we'll look at that as well
so I'm going to go into the pool
requests and the ones that are closed
and just check out the first few so I
don't think I ever gave credit to Otto
for this one but this was a while ago
last week fix that center logo centered
the logo on the sidebar which is awesome
I know also updated material UI to the
latest version so we were on version 26
point two six and we're not we're now on
the latest version which is point two
eight so that's awesome evidently there
were no breaking changes because
everything still works and let's see we
also have let's look at these look in
here at these ones so it makes social
icons larger and Center them great so
for a while I've been bothered by the
social icons being like weirdly
off-center so now the social icons are
bigger so thank you very much
and let's see we also have the the text
for that donate button is now corrected
so now it says access eff us so thank
you for that as well and then we do have
a pull request we have a large pool
request here and this was from on hill
as well and you can see basically this
added a lot of stuff right a header with
the green vacu background for all the
views drawer navigation if you're not
familiar with react native navigation
it's not the same as you'd normally
navigate in a regular react web app so
that's why we're talking about or
navigation I think of like being able to
click links in a side drawer right on an
app that's the kind of navigation we're
talking about which like it's like you
would expect from the name I suppose I
also created the drawer the side menu
added some views added about view and
added an icon to the headers we can
actually click to open the drawer so
that's awesome you can check out all the
changes here you can see quite a few
eight files changed really nice a lot of
good stuff here so if you want to know
more about react native and how we set
this up initially go back and check I
think we called this project six so go
back and check in the the live stream
playlist and find the one that's project
six I think it says react native in the
title almost positive I'll have to
separate this out into its own playlist
at some point but right now we only have
one video so I'm gonna make a playlist
with one video in it so anyway those are
hopefully I didn't miss anything
those are the pull requests that we got
and they're really awesome I'm really
glad that we have some progress here on
this react native thing I don't have any
time right now to work on it but I was
always hoping that somebody would be
interested in getting some practice and
would want to want to work on this a bit
so really glad about that thank you we
also have an electron app if anybody's
interested in electron so basically
using react and electron to make an app
that would could run on Windows iOS or
I'm sorry Mac OS and in Linux could run
as a desktop app so that's also another
project out there it just depends it
depends on you know what you're
interested in so if it's something
you're into then you know please by all
means go ahead if you know ask me what
needs done or I can help walk you
through things just let me know
Harshad says show contributors data
I wonder what's happened all right let
me go to contributors have three
contributors our should our should
you're still number one on this still
number one cool and I guess we can show
contributors data for our Franciscan
react as well I haven't shown that for a
while I do like to show the contributors
data to give you a credit so hey I'm
actually the top contributor on my own
project this time that's good
we got hard [ __ ] close behind so I'll
zoom in on everybody so I can see thank
you everyone who contributed I really
appreciate it okay I'm gonna go to the
live chat now and I'm gonna answer as
many questions as I can if you had any
questions about anything that we've
worked on it doesn't have to be a talk
that we've covered already in the stream
it could be anyone repose we're working
on or just any question in general all
answered pretty much anything as long as
I mean I'll pretty much answer anything
it would be really obvious if
something's not an appropriate question
and I'll just get that but otherwise I'm
I'm open so I'm scrolling way back up to
the top sorry I had a missed call I
think it was spam though just wanted to
check
all right I just get a really surprising
message from my wife Wow
it's nothing bad booth my marriage or
anything like that it's just somebody
that we both know something crazy happen
okay sorry I keep taking drinks if you
weren't here at the beginning I have a
sore throat so I'm just trying to keep
myself from coughing and drinking helps
let's see
all right so Akram says which JavaScript
framework can I start learning you could
start learning any of them that you
really want to if you'd like to be able
to follow along with these streams I
recommend learning react because that's
what we use mostly if you're if you're
really really new to JavaScript I
recommend learning a little bit more
JavaScript before you get into a
framework you don't need to be in
JavaScript expert but sometimes it's
really hard to understand a framework if
you don't have basic knowledge of
JavaScript so I'm not sure where you're
at I don't mean to imply that that you
don't know JavaScript but I don't really
know how much you know so if you're
solid and your JavaScript like I said I
recommend react when it depends on your
goal if you have a company that you
really want to get into that uses
angular go with that if checkout view a
lot of people like view I mean there's
so they're companies that use Ember
there's a lot of stuff out there so but
I would say the top ones right now your
angular and reacts by far the top ones
use getting a lot of more people using
it but it's so it has momentum but it's
not up to the level of angular and react
I mean in terms of like total users and
people people doing things with it
hopefully that answered your question
let me know if you have any follow-ups
to that Dave says thanks for the work
you put into this it has really helped
me a lot oh you're welcome
you're welcome thank you for telling me
and let me know if there's anything I
can do to make the streams better and
more if you have any questions and that
that's not just for day that goes for
anyone if I'm doing something that you
find really annoying or you think that
you have a good
idea for something I could do please let
me know I can't guarantee that I'll
change things based on that but I'll
definitely take it into consideration
and because I know I mean sometimes my
videos get thumbs down I don't care if
they get thumbs down it doesn't really
make me cry or anything but what I
really would like is give the thumbs
down and then put something in the
description that says here's why I gave
you the thumbs down that way I can make
things better
alright that's why I was like on Stack
Overflow you can down vote somebody's
answer if I get a down vote and nobody
tells me why I get a down vote I'm like
well how am I supposed to give you a
better answer next time I have no idea
what you downloaded it I obviously
thought it was a good answer I want to
posted it right so anyway I'm the point
is I'm trying to make is that I I
welcome criticism and your ideas I do
want to make this stream better and more
helpful to your Nisar says Jesse would
you like to see your future full project
with react native compatible with Expo
just pure JavaScript good I'm not
exactly sure everything is going on in
that question but if I'd like to see my
future full project with react native
native that would be cool that would
actually be really cool I don't think
that that's something that my boss even
has on his mind at all about doing the
University does currently have an app I
had nothing to do with with the building
of that app we hired another company to
do it so I think right now he's worried
about just trying to work within that
app structure he's not opposed to me
having other apps though I thought
talked to him about for instance the
Resource Center being a mobile app so I
for sure want this website
to be a progressive web app so I want
people to be able to you know download
the shortcut you know on their phone be
able to use it offline to a certain
extent but if we can turn it into an app
I'm cool with that as well
Fabo Fabo pre oh yes hey Pope the Pope
real I'm trying to remember how to spell
this car how to pronounce that sorry do
Beaupre oh says no one replies like you
do the way you helped us with our
personal projects and open a new tab for
searching about our problems or us is
really exceptional oh thanks for saying
that I mean I don't know honestly some
of it I like don't have a lot of people
following me and I have the luxury being
able to do this from work so a lot of
the other YouTube people or you know
just people on Twitter or Instagram or
whatever sometimes they have a lot of
followers you know I mean I have maybe I
don't know my twitter is like almost 800
followers right there are people on
there that have over a hundred thousand
right so I have a tiny fraction of what
they have so I'm not getting swamped in
my DMS by people so I definitely have
the freedom and the fact that I can do
this at work is part of my work and get
paid for it kind of frees me up a little
bit as well so having said that I mean I
do really like to take the time to
answer everybody the way I see it is I
don't want to be the person that
discourages somebody else and they don't
go into coding I'd rather be the person
that I'll never know it but maybe
somebody was just on the brink of giving
up and I say one encouraging thing and
you know then they go forward right I'll
probably never know about it but that's
really at that point I could either say
something encouraging
or I could you know say nothing or say
something you know derogatory towards
them and then they quit so I don't know
that's how I think when I do stuff like
this and when I try to answer and I'm
not always the best I know there have
been people who've asked me to like
review their portfolio and resume and I
never really got back to them if that
has happened to you please like send me
a message and remind me because
sometimes things just get really really
busy with my work and my family and it
just slips through so I don't want to
pretend like I'm perfect when it comes
to answering but I do try my best and
but you know give the other people a
break as well because I'm sure they have
a lot more going on than I do and
especially I don't want to go on too
much of a tangent but I would kind of
like to mention this because I notice
some of the female coders that I follow
on Twitter and on Instagram they
mentioned sometimes that they get a lot
of direct messages from people and
sometimes they get inappropriate things
message to them or yeah so it's just
hard like I don't get that you know I've
never experienced that as a male
developer when people watch my stuff
they they always talk about my code for
the most part I mean occasionally
somebody makes a comment on whether I
shave my beard or not right but as a
female developer a lot of the comments
have to do with their appearance and
it's like people just ignore their
coding abilities so I just be careful
about that and you know give them a
break too if you try to ask them a
question and that you know they have to
deal with a lot more than I have to deal
with and they've probably had some
really bad experiences before so there
may be a lot more you know careful so
just be straightforward and you know if
you send them a direct message don't
just say hey what's up because they're
probably gonna ignore it right because
they probably get a million of those
and then when they do answer it ends up
being somebody who's you know not very
nice to them so you know maybe say say
something like hey you look like you
really know what you're doing and coding
I'm having this problem you know could
you please answer my question
right you know don't start out with like
you know the heart emojis and the heart
eyes and saying you're so beautiful
and you're good coder like now I mean
I'm sure that's flattering sometimes but
you know if you get that 500 times a day
maybe it gets old I don't know if you
all want to tell me how beautiful I am
you know you I'm open to that that would
be fun but anyway all right that's my
that's my message for the day is
basically in general be nice to
everybody when you do comments but
especially you know just kind of be
aware of what some other coders on
social media on YouTube have to deal
with okay
let me get back to the live chat
oh I shouldn't have said I'm late that I
missed something hard [ __ ] you probably
were able to catch up so let me know if
you didn't and I'll I'll try to catch
you up on things but you didn't really
miss that much and you're super smart so
I'm sure he caught up heart should also
says materialized eliminated jQuery in
version one off to check that out
because when we use materialized for
this they still were dependent on jQuery
but I'm I'm actually really interested
if that's the case that's really
interesting I'll have to check it out I
haven't looked at any of the updates
from materialize in a while since we
started using material you I for most of
our our stuff okay I'm sorry I'm
probably not gonna pronounce this right
Oh goose on says what's the best IDE I'm
I'm currently using
what if you want to consider Visual
Studio code in IDE which some people do
some people don't but if you do want to
consider an IDE I really like Visual
Studio code I've used atom before and I
do like atom as well and you know so I
think there's a lot of IDs out there
that are really close in terms of you
know their functionality but right now
I'm very happy with Visual Studio code
Harshit says so you switch to outlook
how's it working I really like outlook
is a huge improvement over what we did
at before so you know for my personal
stuff I use Gmail but for work I use
outlook and I love it we were using
Novell GroupWise before which is really
ancient and terrible I'm sorry if you
work at Novell GroupWise I'm sure you do
hard work and you're good at your job
but I'm sure you've also inherited a lot
of legacy stuff and it's hard to work
with so if you are working on that like
keep working and do your best but I just
can't in good conscience recommend it to
anybody
their their mobile capabilities would
pretty much non-existent if you're
trying to go through your browser and
yeah it was just not fun to work with so
far I really like Outlook I really love
the outlook app as well and I'm gonna
give a shout out to Murray clemency who
works on the outlook app and I was it
her at November so I'm sure she's not
watching but anyway if anybody knows
Murray or ever meets her she she's done
a great job with the outlook app I'm
really impressed
tope says love the beard Thanks
I had a pull on Instagram yesterday
about whether or not I should shave my
beard and the the overwhelming majority
said I should keep it so it's gonna stay
for a little while which is good because
it's really cold outside
but anything that says you sound a bit
cold make sure you take those D vitamins
I do need to take the vitamins I get no
sunlight and I have I don't know what I
have a cold or something I don't know I
feel I'm trying my best to just ignore
it and pretend like I'm not sick but I'm
so tired let's see Harshit says that
plus/minus things is simple math kind of
distance formula sergeant says
difference of coordinates
Harshit stipend in some math in here and
I should you're better at math than me
because I'm like not even following it
at this point the last math course I
took was so long ago let's see
Harshit says you have not calculated the
whole distance I'll shoot it skipped
down to the bottom I'm sorry I got a
scroll back up you have not calculated
the whole distance but that value works
for comparison for complete accuracy I
would have made the API call to Google
distance matrix API
this gives distance by car playing bike
etc yeah yeah like like I said I was
thinking we'd have to go to that tune
API but then I realized that we don't
really need precise distance this is
just in general also the the problem was
as well it's a lot of times the the
woman who's in charge of doing entering
the data doesn't really even know the
exact location of these events she just
knows the city so
having more precise data wouldn't even
be that helpful so anyway that's but
that's good to point out the ocean so
when we went over how I did the
comparison of locations this hill which
was farther away which was closer that
was just a very general way to do it
because for our use case that was
sufficient if you wanted like people to
actually have your really precise
location you would want to use something
like you know making API to Google and
get to the more precise directions
let's see coding and caffeine says I
need coffee and yeah I could probably do
with another cup of coffee I had like a
half a cup of coffee earlier and it was
what was left over from yesterday and
just heated it up see Gander seven said
okay so this is in response to when I
was talking about browsers and whether
or not it's a good idea to support older
browsers particularly when you're
thinking of what's the best thing for
the user to support the browsers or not
and to try to encourage them to upgrade
their browsers so Gander 7 says agreed
we only support current browsers it is
possible to let's see all right the next
the next statement doesn't have to do
with that but yeah I'm starting to think
like that as well that I should only
support newer browsers but make have an
easy way to explain to users and that
they need to upgrade and then have links
available for them to upgrade ganda 7
also says is it possible to create an
electron app that is self-contained load
URLs loads load file and handle react
j/s versus load a server or localist
i've been trying to find
I've been trying mecan't find a way
mmm I'm not really sure so I I have
never successfully made an electron
react app yet we just got one started so
we basically have like a hello world app
running and it works but you know that's
that's not really like I made I made an
app so I don't really know but if you
want to follow along with our project I
can't tell you for sure when I'm gonna
have time to work on it
but maybe you know in the process of
that you know we'll have to answer that
question
John Hanson's here says hi Oh late I was
eating yeah no problem
Harshit says I'm I'm busy nowadays so
I'm not able to contribute yeah I
totally understand I you told me school
story and everything so you've
contributed so much hard [ __ ] I really
appreciate it so don't don't worry it I
don't know if you're worrying about it
hopefully not because you don't need to
worry at all you've done so much and I I
do I appreciate that and everybody here
in my department appreciates it I told
them at meetings how much work you have
done so they they all know that you've
done you know really good work and I
even told him I said our shirts better
than me he does great work like it's
easy
he's awesome so you do what you have to
do for school and don't worry about this
John says it's hard to do on page X page
Y or client ex-client y on different
screens and devices okay I'm not sure it
was that was that was directed to harsh
it for something
oh cool harsh it says checkout ants
design it's like material design but
they made it completely for react all
right cool it's it dot design let me I'm
gonna type it in on my other screen here
so don't forget
all right just scrolling through their
website their website looks good so
that's that's a good sign right off the
bat got a lot of stars on github very
cool I'll check that out later thanks
thanks for the the link Arshavin says
how to differentiate between admin and
user in authentication please help me to
get the knowledge I'm using react I'll
definitely need some more info for that
but I'm happy to help if I can a
hardship respondent said are you using
JSON web tokens or cookies let's see
okay so Stalin is using JSON web tokens
and firebase all right it looks like
hard [ __ ] is is offering some advice on
that so I'm gonna defer to harsh because
I know these were experienced with that
kind of stuff and harsh is coming from
back end and moving into front end stuff
as well so that's something that he's
gonna be way more familiar with I'm
coming from front end and learning more
about back-end and using it let's see I
lost my place here
Harshit said do you know oh sorry John
Hanson says for some odd reason Learning
pub for HTML taught me a lot when it
came to learning JavaScript that's cool
that's cool I am back when pug was
called Jade I did some stuff with it but
I've not used it for really long time at
least a year or more Isis says do you
know it cost points to download in Stack
Overflow I didn't realize I don't think
I've ever downloaded anything in Stack
Overflow usually if there's a terrible
answer it's already been downloaded or
downloaded so many times it's like why
even bother gander seven says you got
one more on Twitter now awesome thanks
right yeah if if you do follow me on
Twitter I do tweet about when I'm gonna
stream and what I'm gonna stream about
so it might be helpful for you to decide
whether or not you want to watch a
stream on a particular day and I also
will retweet like if you tweet and say
you're looking for a job or you need
advice on something and I see that like
I'll retweet it so if you want to like
tag me in the tweet so I definitely see
it you know go ahead and do that and you
know I'm more than happy like I said I
don't have that many people following me
but I get you some exposure you know
maybe you can get some more retweets
from other people that have a bigger
following so I can't really do much more
than that but I'll do what I can for you
Oh har she completed the the new West
boss grade course that's awesome that
just came out like yesterday right good
job on that he said it was very good so
that's really cool so if you want to
learn more about CSS grid check out the
new course from West boss at CSS grid
dot IO it's completely free so go ahead
and check that out I definitely want to
check it out I just have a lot going on
right now so I don't know if I'm going
to be able to but at some point I do
want to check that out
Ola sauce says it's good to see
real-life project working process I'm
still new in web development so touching
everything here and there so I just
wanted to say thank you for your streams
it helps in motivates oh you welcome
you're welcome comments like that help
and motivate me so I'm glad I'm glad you
said that and I'm glad that my stream is
is helping you out Pollux says where to
learn best practices about reacting
JavaScript really the the react
documentation is a good place to go mmm
I think with JavaScript best practices I
mean mdn Mozilla developer Network is
good if you want to learn about specific
parts of JavaScript otherwise I mean
maybe a book series like like you don't
know J s is free online eloquent
JavaScript is a free book online and you
can buy the paper version of it as well
but those are good places to learn more
about JavaScript you can check out some
JavaScript style guides from big
companies like Airbnb has a very popular
style guide for JavaScript standard Jas
has one those can help I mean and in
terms of like how how should you
properly format and do things if anyone
else has any suggestions on
please put it in the in the live chat
michael says hey oh it's been a while
hey Michael how's it going thanks for
joining
let's see arch is still trying to help
serve on with his authentication
questions and one of the harshest
responses was it's easy I can show you
how harsh it makes everything looks easy
some of the things that that you can do
are probably easy to you but not not to
Mesa so just remember that if I should
tell you something's easy it may not
actually be easy
david says vitamins are a scam even if
the vitamins are just a placebo effect
for me I'll take it at this point I
don't really care because I just I want
to not be sick and have more energy
oh okay hard shoots at school hasn't
started yet it was started on 13th of
February
okay John says the Google Maps API has a
way to put directions from the visitors
location it's fairly simple to implement
in a website it's to put it in a react
app is a bit more tricky
alright that's really cool like I said
for this app I don't think it's
necessary but that's good to know I it
would actually be really cool to do that
and some of the other stuff that I've
been working on some like previous sites
ice I have a previous site that's not a
reactor where that could be really
useful I think so when I have time at
some point maybe we'll add that in Evo
says hi hey Eva how's it going thanks
for joining
George asks if there's any firebase
projects coming in the future
I can't say for sure I love to work with
firebase I've learned a little bit about
it and heard other people use it and
heard them talk about it so I'm really
interested but I'd have to find some way
to work it into project and if I can
I'll work with it but like I said I
can't can't guarantee anything let's see
sorry I don't know exactly how to
pronounce this name is BER ke so Barrett
Barrack burka says can you suggest a
source to learn react for beginners
check out the tutorial from the actual
react website that's a good place to
start code Academy has a tutorial that
would probably be good to go through
free code camp their new beta curriculum
has some react stuff in there I haven't
tried it yet but usually the free code
camp stuff is pretty good so those
places I think are a good place to start
John says Jen Simmons has started a new
YouTube channel called layout and layout
land
she knows CSS grid like no one else
alright really cool I have to check that
out thanks for that job
well Harshit said she wrote it spec wow
that's I would say she knows it
that's you read the spec that's really
cool Carson said she even kind of
corrected West's boss for making him
perfect advice on the grid on Twitter
Wow
alright maybe I was to check out that
YouTube channel I like YouTube videos
for code stuff because like when I'm
eating
I usually just eat in my office at my
desk and I watch a video some type of
coding tutorial or something so I'm
always looking for for new videos or
useful things Evo says doing pretty good
signed my contract today with which I
can start working next Monday awesome
awesome congratulations I understand
you'll probably be pretty busy but if
you could remember let me know like how
your first day goes your first week or
whatever I'm really interested in that
so so don't forget about us when you're
you know busy building cool things and
making lots of money alright well I've
gotten to the bottom of the live chat
and I think I'm gonna wrap things up now
I can't believe I've been streaming for
almost an hour and a half ok now's a
great time then it's Friday so we're
gonna have the weekend I'll be back most
likely on Monday there is a storm that's
gonna come through maybe sometime next
week so if it storms really bad and I
can't make it into work probably won't
have a stream so just be aware that
there may be some days when I can't
stream next week just depending on what
happens with the weather otherwise I'm
playing
every day if I can let's see one more
comment I'll read this out Evo says
about the video watching and coding one
thing I noticed is that non-programmers
find it weird that we really enjoy
learning more about our expertise oh
that's interesting that is true you know
if coders seem like we love what we're
doing like we watch stuff we go home and
think about code we may have side
projects like yeah I give me an I guess
you don't see that in every every
profession that's cool we're passionate
about what we do we really like it and
that's a good thing so if you don't
overdo it you know ignore your family
and your health and anything like that
but anyway that's a good observation Evo
all right so have a wonderful weekend
everyone thank you so much for watching
and for all your help in the live chat I
will be back Monday see ya